miles i'm conflicted on this
on one hand i like it well i'm
conflicted on many things but
specifically on this
on one hand i like it when a football
organization football coach whoever
acknowledges a mistake
and tries to fix it on the other hand
it was a pretty big mistake last year
and the cowboys knew what they were
getting into changing up their defensive
philosophy without the personnel
necessary to implement it hiring mike
nolan to be the defensive coordinator
when there were plenty of other capable
candidates out there granted dan quinn
had another job last year he couldn't be
hired by the cowboys to be the defensive
coordinator he was the head coach of the
falcons but still
the fact that they are making such
dramatic changes to the defensive side
of the ball after only one year of mike
mccarthy is an embarrassment to the
organization it's an embarrassment to
mccarthy it shouldn't have gone this
poorly this quickly and it doesn't
inspire a lot of confidence that it's
magically going to get better
well i think that if you're going to say
there is confidence that it will get
better would have to be because of the
guy that they hired to be the defensive
coordinator and granted dan quinn's
defenses in atlanta were never really
that great i mean even that team that
went to the super bowl that defense was
ranked in the 20s with both uh in terms
of scoring and yardage so and then only
the year after that were both they
ranked in the top 10 for both yardage
and scoring in terms of defense so
you have to go back to 2013 and 2014 and
say look what he did when he was just
the defensive coordinator and what he
did when he was just in charge of that
defense to say yes i think dan quinn is
a great defensive coordinator and he can
come in and he can play that rule but
look i don't know that you can get much
worse than what mike nolan was doing
last year and the way that they try to
transition that defense and frankly i
feel like even when mike nolan was hired
people had some trepidation as to what
they thought mike nolan could really do
with that defense given the fact that he
just had not necessarily been a very
good defensive coordinator in a long
time right am i making that up mike
well no and and look that's the thing
and when when a coach is hired
sometimes it is a challenge to get the
coordinators you really want i don't
know how much and and uh this may this
answer may be out there mike mccarthy
had a whole year where it created this
little laboratory in wisconsin where
they were working and preparing and i
don't know if nolan was his first choice
as defensive coordinator for a full year
or not i may have known that at some
point if i did i've forgotten the answer
to that but back to dan quinn
this is one of the dangers
and i like dan quinn and he did a great
job overall with the falcons but for the
28-3 collapse he would have had a super
bowl championship but he's a defensive
coordinator who came from a team that
had a defensive system that has worked
with multiple coordinators and the head
coach is a defensive mastermind so
now you've got dan quinn
taking over the dallas defense working
for a coach who isn't a defensive
mastermind as evidenced by last season
you delegate half of the ball i've never
been a big fan of that of delegating an
entire half of the ball
to a coordinator when you're the head
coach
and i know that there's involvement but
a lot of these defensive coaches hand
the keys to the offense to the
coordinator a lot of offensive coaches
hand the keys to the defense to the
defensive coordinator so this image of
sean mcvay his first year with the rams
he's sitting on top of a cooler mapping
out plays for the next offensive drive
while wade phillips is running the team
so
if you're going to do that if you're
going to delegate the defense to dan
quinn
has he ever really been
a defensive coordinator you could argue
he really hasn't been in the classic
sense of being the guy who ran the
defense for an offensive head coach that
gives me a little bit of pause and again
the same people who made the decision
that they would have said all sorts of
optimistic and
colorful flowery things about last year
and surely did we could probably dig up
the quotes about how good the defense
was going to be and how mike nolan was
going to come in and do this and do that
they got it wrong how can we have faith
that they're going to get it right this
year when they got it so wrong last year
well i mean it's mostly because you have
no other choice right i mean they're in
the nfc east so that's one thing that's
working for them at the very least
because
you can at least look at say washington
you know philadelphia
and the giants and say well are those
three teams really going to have that
much explosive offenses and those the
two those are the three teams that you
have to play twice a year so i feel like
if there's some optimism it would be
because of that what division you're in
also because there are some pieces that
are still very talented or at least
moderately talented that are on that
dallas defense like lawrence i mean he's
an edge rusher he's been very good at
times and not have the best season in
2020 but then again nobody did on that
defense van der esch what kind of
happened to him last year as well he's
somebody that if you get him back into
form and especially the way he looked as
a rookie then maybe you've really got
something there so i just feel like
yeah i don't know that i trust
what they're gonna do either and that
it's all going to work but at least they
are in a position where they admitted
their mistake they can clearly see that
they made a mistake and now they're
trying to rectify it and they're trying
to get better
again that's why i'm conflicted i give
them credit for recognizing their
mistake i don't give them credit for
making such a horrendous mistake that
went off the rails so quickly and
obviously and let's face it miles the
termination of mike nolan was a foregone
conclusion the question was were they
going to do it in october or maybe
september that's how bad it was right
out of the gates so
they got it wrong they're trying to get
it right but the same people who got it
wrong are the ones who are making the
decision this time around in an effort
to get it right and i don't know that
mccarthy is on the hot seat
jerry jones doesn't like to admit that
he has made mistakes in a significant
and dramatic way and even though he's
got tons of money he's not a big fan of
paying buyouts so i think mccarthy is
safe no matter what but at the same time
mccarthy's
super bowl win from 2010 may as well be
from 1910 given the way that his teams
have played in recent years of his
coaching career up to the point where he
was fired by the packers with a month
left in the season and in 2020 his first
year with the dallas cowboys we'll see
how it goes open mind and we'll see
new defensive coordinator and the proof
will be in how many points the opponents
score on a per game basis
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports